you are obviously no stranger to seeing
your work on screen but what has the
experience been like of seeing a graphic
novel of yours adapted to a new medium
um it's
it's such a like leap of faith I think
to uh kind of let a story go and let it
go and be what it has to be
um and so you know from the start I was
like I have told my story The Graphic
novel exists that is like that version
of the story now it's gonna go and be
whatever it's going to be but it is
scary it's like you know is it gonna be
are they choices I'm gonna agree with or
is it gonna feel like the same story the
same characters and to be here at the
end of it and and feel just still like
to still be so connected to this
property and to have been able to be
such a part of the process of creating
this movie and getting just to like
spend continue to spend time with these
characters in this world that means so
much to me it's been like I I try not to
take a moment of it for granted because
it's not something that every creator of
the source material can say about the
adaption of their work
um it's just been a real honor to be
included in the process of this movie
and Nick and Troy always just like kept
that conversation open and always just I
I am so grateful to every single person
on that production because I can't
imagine the movie being in better hands
so I wonder what were the big challenges
in jumping from medium to medium like in
terms of changes that had to be made and
stuff like that I think that there are a
lot of things that um
work in a comic and you have more
ability to
you have a certain ability to to
introduce plot points um and let them
kind of lead wherever they go and um
with an animated movie you have to
really hone in on what's important
because you just like you really need to
find that you need to stick with that so
every time it starts wandering too much
you you kind of risk losing the
characters or losing the emotion
um and so I think there were it's like
it's a world that is so intriguing that
has so much going on in it and there was
always like the desire to explore and
know more about it but it was
challenging because as soon as you start
like getting more into the rules of the
world and the setting and like all of
those other things that can be so cool
and so fun to like geek out about you
start losing sight of the characters and
this story really is just defined by
those characters and so when Nick I
think one thing that Nick and Troy did
that was like really really smart which
was just like always bring it back to
its most simple version and always make
it about the emotion of the characters
uh and their relationships to each other
so I think that that was like
um it's it's difficult to like it's it's
hard to like identify what that is
especially once you've been with it for
a while
um and you really just have to come to
it with fresh eyes and be like what is
the most simple like uh Elemental
version of this story and how do we stay
true to that so like I said you have
been with this
for any moment scene beat interaction
that really like sticks out to you like
wow as if you are seeing it for the
first time uh the the Final Act always
hits me really hard everything from
nimona's uh flashback to her friendship
with glorious like up to her Rampage
through the city that was really why you
know having nimona
become this being of pure rage was
something that like I people were
nervous about it even as a graphic novel
when you do have more freedom to kind of
be more you know push those boundaries a
little bit more
um it's like the book is like weirdly
gory every time I look back at it I'm
like wow you really got into drawing all
that blood
but it was like how do you find that
version that's um that's family friendly
but also like doesn't sand down those
rough edges because she is a character
in this story is all about those rough
edges the the anger and the grief and
the loneliness and the messiness all of
that is like who she is and why I wanted
to tell this story so I think like
seeing that represented of her being of
her letting that monster out after a
lifetime of being told she's a monster
it's I am just so glad that that made it
to the screen and that they did such a
beautiful job with it and found so much
emotion in that
um it's definitely uh it is definitely
like I always hear the sniffles in the
audience at that point and sometimes
like more than sniffles it's so
emotional and it's so it it just blows
my mind to see it represented like that
on the screen it's I think it's really
gonna I think it's really gonna heal a
lot of Hearts because I know that it's
healed mine so this is quite the time to
be like a fan of Animation it's just an
unparalleled moment I guess what what do
you think it is about a story like this
that lends off so naturally to that
Medium I mean I think there's so much so
much of the story is about motion um
it's something you can't really do in a
comic like I can't literally transform
her from one thing to the other I can
only like you know imply that or or
stylize that in some way and I think to
see her like to see that explosion of
movement and watch her change between
these different forms in this like
unbroken line of action it is something
that like it brings the story to life in
a whole new way
and it's you know comics and animation
are very different mediums and yet they
are they are in conversation they have a
lot in common and I think that they
found this like much more cinematic and
and like that they found that fluidity
of movement and that freedom of movement
that really just brings her as a
character to life and when she comes to
life the rest of the world comes to life
too I thought the fluidity was so so
perfect because it's so inherent to who
she is there's no stop and start it is
yeah absolutely
um so what do you hope audiences take
away from from this movie when they
watch it I think that um yeah I touched
on it just a second ago but uh I was
really struck watching it at the world
premiere with like a packed theater and
hearing and seeing the emotion as people
responded to the movie and I realized
that like I was sort of like I had put
my soul into this comic and into this
character and really
ripped all these emotions out and laid
them out for others to to read and to
see and relate to and the feeling of
that that was happening at that moment
too and it was a little scary for a like
for some of it I was really nervous it
felt very vulnerable but then to feel
that love and all the energy of just
like people like relating to nimona
seeing themselves in nimona and as a
character who came out of a time when I
just felt really lonely and angry and
scared and lost
it felt like it was reaching back and
soothing that part of me and accepting
that part of me and I really hope that
it does that for everyone who watches it
because I do think that like there's a
little like we do
I think everyone kind of sees a little
of themselves in nimona and I really
just like I want people to
to know that just like her they're
they're worthy of love